[Music]
so last week we actually played a video
of arie spears and it was very funny
video wasn't making fun of liz
it was [ __ ] hilarious and then we we
obviously immediately uh
threw our support 100 percent behind
aries 100 i mean we kindly we call them
the next patrice yeah we basically said
that um
no matter what happens and no matter
what comes out about the guy ever he
we're always going to have his back what
happened right well here's the thing so
before before we hit play
um tape or do me a favor if you're
clipping this right here that thing that
you clipped you could play us laughing
about it and saying how funny is put
that right here okay cool
oh
yeah another uh you know somebody
another guy black guy who always says
what's on his mind yeah they actually
make gary spears
lizzo
yeah bro how you heard her [ __ ] yo like
as a songwriter yo i i can't get past
the fact that she looks like the [ __ ]
emoji
oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
oh god
sir you dropped your crown
i
i think very often people forget
how [ __ ] good arie spears is
and he is ruthless
holy [ __ ]
he he said he's been holding on to it
i
i remember arie spears very famous story
he almost got into a fight with paul and
young ron in south florida which was the
local two radio guys there
because he came on and they kept trying
to like to get him to do impressions but
like really poorly like it was like what
would mike tyson sound like yo man can
we just like talk about like i'm doing
stand-up and like i've got a show and
[ __ ] like i don't want to have to
[ __ ] you know
like jump through hoops and like you
know be your monkey you know do whenever
you want me to do impressions and they
got into this whole like this whole
fight about it like you know eric spears
is [ __ ] nuts dude he doesn't care
yeah he will he'll fight you
bro how you heard her [ __ ] yo like as a
songwriter yo
i i can't get past the fact that she
looks like the [ __ ] emoji
very beautiful girl she got a very
pretty face
but she keeps showing her body off [ __ ]
like come on man
come on yo
honestly there's never been a better way
to describe it than that that's so fair
the way come on man
i'm sorry listen i ain't the most in
shape [ __ ]
in the world but i still you know when
you funny and you got swagger and
confidence
and and you decent looking i think i'm
at least handsome
you get [ __ ]
but a one he's actually not wrong about
that statement i mean it's built like a
plate of mashed potatoes is in trouble
like a plate of mashed potatoes
is he getting anything is he getting any
backlash from this uh you don't think he
i don't know but i don't think lizzo
fans and the body positive people i
don't think they give a [ __ ]
sorry this is why i can't hate black
people dude
[Laughter]
he's killing
but
musically yo she go hard man she's a
good songwriter though oh yo she's yeah
she's dope
her music hard her body ache
oh here they come to the wall of
braveheart [ __ ]
look we don't have patrice and in no way
am i saying
that airy spears is on the same others
patrice we need to keep the good ones we
have but it's something
the field
coming over here brooklyn patrice yeah
kirkland patrice i'll take it are you
ready for a war
you can hear the horses thumping on the
[ __ ] ground he's about to
oh he here he come who that [ __ ]
think he is be body shame and fat
[ __ ]
you know what kills me about women
oh this is going to be good hey guys get
comfortable this is the hypocrisy in the
contradiction yes queen slay queen your
ass queen slag yeah girl your confidence
[ __ ] diabetes [ __ ]
heart heart problems [ __ ] heart disease
cholesterol
y'all claim womanhood and about
sisterhood and support for your sister
you know when it comes to that
ridiculous [ __ ] but if you really gave a
[ __ ] why wouldn't you go black girl we
love you we love your confidence boo boo
but this ain't it this ain't it
where's that's the real love y'all are
jumping okay aries here i can help you
on this one buddy i got you
women [ __ ] hate each other yeah and
they want to push people like lizzo up
that way there's always somebody that
they could look at and go
oh i'm not her
nowadays women can say that i'm hotter
than a [ __ ] pop star too yeah exactly
good point
jump on me for making jokes but y'all
won't [ __ ] be real and go sister put
the eclair down
the same egg
i like that she's eating a fancy french
dessert
and by the way merch i will not be going
to paris i heard a rap song and there
are african americans there now male 1
well there sure are speaking of that
right because she does have issues with
her weight right and it's actually i
mean yeah that's a good video online of
her crying about being fat shame did you
see the video of her crying we all do i
do but yeah man she said she'd be having
an issue man with people fast shaming
her about her weight and cracking jokes
about how big she is well how you gonna
have issues but at the same time show
your whole ass
at an nba game
[Laughter]
i mean my man's got a point
my man's got a [ __ ] point
he's the best you can't show your ass
crackers
noticed it he's right though right he's
a hundred percent right
oh [ __ ]
as comedians we take what the defense
gives us
you don't want to be put out there then
don't put it out there
and again
i know i listen i never met a plate of
pasta i didn't like
i'm a pasta whoa [ __ ]
i'm you know i'm trying it's an everyday
struggle for me
you know i i you know i come from a
family where you know we drank fried
milkshakes
what the [ __ ] even is a fried milk i
think it's probably joking yeah
obviously
but bro i mean he is on [ __ ] spears
has never not been fun point dude he's
always been one of the top people of
course
damn man that was [ __ ] just an
evisceration of her that was great [ __ ]
emoji is brutal that was brutal yeah
now
here's what happened uh from
the spongebob
one week later
and welcome back to the factor
uncensored very shocking allegations of
child abuse against tiffany haddish and
arie spears a new lawsuit against the
comedians have accused the comedians of
sexually abusing two child actors during
the filming of a skit had it
so here's the thing
i know that we were laughing earlier and
we're having fun
you gotta understand something
at the time we were not aware [ __ ] harry
spears i never liked that piece of [ __ ]
i never trust him
fish hasn't spoken out about the alley
maybe well another thing is this
literally came out the day after we did
the day
i sent it to merch over the weekend i'm
like bro no [ __ ] way
is denying all charges and calling the
allegations bogus backstage oil.com's
dave morales says he was shocked to hear
the news
dave morales okay i don't need dave
morales because i cuz dave morales is
you know whatever but but here's what
i'm going to do i'm going to i'm going
to go ahead and uh
read the story tiffany haddish and arie
spears accused of child sexual abuse in
a lawsuit their reps called it a
shakedown now i'm going to read this and
then we're going to
tell you what we think okay comedians
tiffany haddish
okay and airy spears have been accused
of having groomed and molested two then
minor siblings years ago according to a
lawsuit filed in la superior court the
complaints are referred to as the
complainants are referred to as jane doe
and john doe in the suit which states
their names are being withheld to
protect their privacy
according to the complaint the copy
which was obtained by cnn jane doe and
john doe were 14 and 7 respectively when
they alleged that haddish and spears had
them participate in a sexually
suggestive video
in separate incidents in 2013. okay
where's this video we could just look at
the video we could tell you right away
uh the video was on funny or die and it
was taken down
i'm trying to find it yeah because i
mean this seems like a simple one that
we could just look at the video and we
could be like oh yeah no that's [ __ ]
you know or not supposedly i heard
that the video
was a spoof
where
like arie spears was literally playing a
child in the last day like it was edgy
boy comedy from what i know
one reason i mean i don't think they
molested a kid and then uploaded the
evidence to like funny or die
okay so it says here when reach for a
comment by cnn attorneys for haddish and
spears called the allegations bogus in a
shakedown according to he said it's
bogus dude according to the complaint
haddish was a longtime family friend of
the mother of the siblings who father
according to the complaint haddish was a
long time family friend of the mother of
the siblings who followed okay right
here can i say red flag number one
this feels like a shakedown i'm not
i don't know any i'm not gonna obviously
not gonna die in a hill because i don't
know everything but i am saying 100 that
this is
arie spears did nothing wrong i am
taking a legally actionable no no no no
you're not no no no no you could do take
a legally action stance on night wave
you can do that on night wave do not do
not
wrote me into this
i just agree with this gentleman i am
making a legally i do not say legally
half of myself nope nope
nope nope no child has ever been known
oh god no and if you can prove that one
child has ever been molested in this
world sue us
you were molested marsh you were
oh maybe i could sue us
aside from somebody means that it exists
now the video showed what dave well it
showed uh you know improper behavior
tiffany and aries were doing a comedy
sketch with miners
and it involved uh what
the plaintiffs are saying lewd
activities uh and then so they haven't
even named him it's jane and john doe or
the plaintiffs but the mom and there's
drama there because the mom brought the
case but now the daughter who is
representing herself in the lawsuit and
you've heard that expression you know
the
what is it the worst client that
attorney have is when you represent
yourself you know the expression yeah
and so there's there's some funny
interesting stuff on the other side as
well but what they're alleging is that
when these children were young they were
in a comedy sketch that aries and
tiffany produced and it involved
bad stuff uh
and so
you know we'll see what happens but
what kind of analysis was that
this guy added nothing and everybody's
saying it looks like uh bobby kelly with
cancer yeah exactly uh they're saying
they're asking if this is another jim
norton character you know what dude it's
like you know you know you're making a
comedy skit and they accuse you of being
a pedo that's what it is it looks like
jim norton doing a bobby yeah [ __ ]
kelly impression exactly
or die has nuked this [ __ ] video off
the face of the planet
i've gone through like three different
art of [ __ ] uh
all right so [ __ ] i'll put it out
there for everybody the name of the the
the skit is uh through a pedophile's eye
okay
so [ __ ] okay so look i i again did
this seems [ __ ] weird to me i i'm
just saying like i'm thinking back to
that time frame and everybody was kind
of making these edgy boy jokes like i'm
not saying like look my point is this if
you're gonna make that comparison right
and this is this is the standard that i
that i that i hold these allegations to
okay
i always use exhibit a is what
happened in that skit worse than this
disney movie
i should have known hey you know i
wouldn't have traded that night for
anything
is what happened in that skit worse than
this oh my god is i have to know
what arie spears is getting sued for is
it worse than this this is she kissed
the kid at the end of big too no but at
least that kid was like a teenager
no i don't i don't think she kissed him
in kid version maybe she did i don't
remember you might be right i think she
did on the cheek on the cheek i think
okay that's fine by the way you got that
the the the woman
the character [ __ ] bag is the only
woman that i honestly feel bad for
because she didn't know she was
literally an accidental pedophile
and it wasn't her fault this is one of
those times you could go look
this is not this lady's fault she just
thought he was a quirky guy you know
what i mean
um so yeah that's what i always hold
anything up to is it worse than the kiss
and blank check
i am just saying just like you know
i feel like there's [ __ ] going on
here and i'm not
again the problem is two things number
one they're not saying who the people's
names are now one of them i understand
because that person would no no would
still be under under under 18. but the
other person was seven another person's
a [ __ ] grown ass person now you know
so
that whenever they do this it also makes
it hard for you to
really get a picture of what's going on
you know what i mean by the way people
priority know who it is because all you
have to do is figure out who is in that
sketch and you'll know exactly who it is
you know uh representative for funny or
die told the daily beast funny or died
found this video absolutely disgusting
and would never produce such content we
were not involved with the
conceptualization development funding or
production of this video it was uploaded
to the site as user-generated content
and was removed in 2018 immediately
after becoming aware of its existence
now they could just be covering their
ass but no no hold on hold on i will i'm
going to give funny or die a little bit
of slack
wait a second wait a second because i
was just about to say that [ __ ] funny
or die also had a [ __ ] skit back in
the day called peter uh
peter the pedophile
where like a kid met a pedophile and
they've also nuked that one off the face
of the [ __ ] planet
so funny or die is also being a [ __ ]
scumbag piece of shit's here because
they've done sketches like this before
forget done sketches [ __ ] the entire
site was founded on will ferrell
offering beer to a little girl because
she was she was the [ __ ] um landlord
which by the way i don't find any of
that offensive i i i and that doesn't
offend me i think that's just funny like
you know what i mean like i think some i
honestly believe that sometimes people
get a little too up their own ass about
jokes sometimes and that's why i'm like
i would need to see the video right like
i would need to see
specifically what they think was bad and
also why would you wait until tiffany
haddish is now starring in big movies
because she wasn't before to start suing
them right why don't you why don't you
sue tiffany haddish that was doing open
mics why are you suing the t why why why
didn't you sue the tiffany hatties that
could only upload videos the funny or
die is user-generated content and not
that tiffany haddish is starring in
[ __ ] movies with uh a-list actors now
you know what i mean
as a matter of fact i think she was in
the nicholas cage movie that i just
watched the whatever one with a
tremendous talent of whatever
anyway man look i don't know i would
need more information and i would like
to see the skit obviously we're not
gonna solve it but i just ha i don't
know man something about this seems
weird to me you know
like it is absolutely not sitting right
with me
this is this is the skit
that airy spears is getting in trouble
for
so
i haven't seen it have you you haven't
seen it yet has anybody seen it yet
no no i purposefully avoided it
okay what the [ __ ]
so he's getting in trouble for those who
might have missed yesterday he's getting
in trouble because according to a cnn
article uh him and tiffany haddish in
like 2014
did a skit that they uploaded to
funnyordi.com
and it was a skit that was called the
mind of a pedophile though the two kids
at the time that were in this video
are now suing him because they say it
was you know there was that this filming
this was sexual abuse
so i we don't know we haven't seen it
so
we were gonna watch it but we should we
were like let's not watch it on our main
channel because i'm a little worried
about that so we figured we'd watch it
here with the boys on patreon um
i guess we'll play it
bro write out the gay pedophile spelled
wrong
yeah i think they did it on purpose is
the point so let's see
oh uncle pete look at me i need you to
do me a big favor please can you do me a
favor and watch tj while i run to the
bank no problem i'll be right back look
do whatever uncle pete asked you to do
okay be good all right thank you so much
if you need anything just call me okay
see
all right now
let me finally cut out the kind of shirt
off or whatever
yeah that's a little
is there anything is there any spirit is
there spears doing a a bill cosby
impression there what was you saw that
it really does feel very
that that looks like a cosby you know
yeah it looks kind of cosby
it's also not really funny yet but maybe
it'll get funny
okay i do not like him
in his underwear that's much i don't
hate this mind
i i don't know i don't i don't i think
you can make a funny joke out of a
concept out of what he's trying to do
here
but i feel like the kid doesn't need to
be naked for it
which one's the funny guy
i think peele
like this is all right trevor moore did
this [ __ ] right when he did sketches
with children
yeah it would film the kids and they
would just ask that you know what i mean
and then they would have him in a
separate pan but yeah let's get that off
the screen that's a little yeah they had
their clothes on virginia yeah they had
their clothes on
trevor moore did the like like when he
did the explaining 911 to kids
yeah yeah but that was like
you know
that was filmed right and also
everything he said was true
and they were clothed
and they were my mind's telling me no
oh i hate this
ah this is
even look
the rough one everyone made edgy jokes i
just i did
even for that era of edginess i'm not
seeing
the funny
i'm not seeing the joke yet but let's
get it i got it you guys don't get the
joke you guys don't get the joke he
wants to [ __ ] the kid oh no no that's
disgusting but what's the joke no no no
that's the funny thing i don't like
imagine if this kid gets [ __ ] let me
let me
you're like i don't get that that's
let me let me i feel like whoever comes
up with that concept doesn't know comedy
very well i'm starting but i mean but
the thing is though and you know we have
to be honest
airy spears knows comedy like he is a
funny guy this isn't funny but we've we
literally just laughed the other day at
some [ __ ] he was saying he's a funny guy
i don't get this but like
even for being edgy it's like i i i
should be hilariously laugh like you
want a funny way to do this like
who another person who films really well
when it comes when it comes around to
like having kids on like the little buff
boy sketch from tim robinson is a great
way to do it where
obviously it's ridiculous
but it's never feels weird you know it's
ridiculous because they're all wearing
body suits you know or or the the it's
always sunny one oh always tell your
friends little darlings yes yes that's
another great example kid beauty pageant
don't dare okay he was his business
partner that turned out to be the
pedophile don't doodle kids dude him
with the [ __ ] the tissue in his nose
bleeding
oh my god clyde has a good point are we
ignoring that they're using r kelly
music
oh boy oh that mate well well 2014 you
know wasn't a big deal i guess
i
must confess
i want to get through this so let's just
get through this okay
[Applause]
i don't like this i don't want to do
this i'm skipping i can't
no no no no no no let me tell you right
now my verdict is that's [ __ ] gross
bro it's [ __ ] bad i was trying to
give the benefit of the doubt i really
was
but at one point i think the kid's
jerking off a train set bro and i'm not
kidding you i'm not [ __ ] kidding you
do you guys ever have that friend in
high school where it's like everyone's
like yeah we're all you're all making
jokes riffing off each other and there's
that one like hang on guy who just goes
like yeah
that's and then you're just like whoa
okay um all right that's what this is
this is this is this is yeah that was
but that bothered me
just i'm not going to play but just want
to show you a quick screen grab does
that look okay to you
that's it
bro i had to go take a dab [ __ ] all that
noise i remember harry spears lizzo
never did that bro what the actual
[ __ ] bro this was an overreaction but
i don't think it was much of an
overreaction
not even remotely so you know what i'm
going to do because i was going to have
taper you know clip you know like i said
that i'm gonna also then add have him
add
blurring out the screen obviously
have him at us
reacting to it to kind of round the
whole thing out you know what i mean
it's awful yeah
yeah
i did not like that i feel uncomfortable
my gum one of my gumroad videos
literally has a man with a whole foot in
his ass and this was worse
this is far worse
bro what the [ __ ] was that
i felt more uncomfortable with that
than i did with the [ __ ] roach milk
and if you'd like to know what i'm
referring to pessi's gumroad i feel
terrible
yeah i don't feel good i feel like sick
like a pit of my stomach i'm so sad
i just honestly thought that it was just
a bunch of people
that
were know people overreacting this
because you know there's some edgy stuff
you know what i mean but this was like
weird bro
look can i say something i want to be
clear i don't think airy spears wants to
[ __ ] kids or [ __ ] those kids i don't
believe that i really don't i don't
think there's anything else he's ever
done that would point out or tiffany
haddish either that would point to that
i do think
that i know they were trying to go for a
joke
but bro
even
if the kid wasn't in his underwear maybe
i tried you know what i mean like if the
kid was wearing clothes
but it's still kind of weird but it's
just still no i didn't see why was he
jerking off a train
i
i don't know exactly how i feel about
how that court case is gonna go
but
like
can we agree that maybe that child that
that kid does have some [ __ ]
repercussions from that yeah i think the
mom might have some legitimate gripes
here yeah they're [ __ ] there's
there's absolutely some pedophiles out
there [ __ ] watching that [ __ ] [ __ ]
now dude you know what i mean yeah
that dude has to live with that [ __ ]
here let's let's think back let's think
back to regular to to better days
oh
that's simpler don't you feel better
everyone movies were good yeah they
might yeah dude remember that remember
listen say what you want about harvey
weinstein but those films were great
i mean there's not been any good movies
since me too question
you if you were harvey weinstein would
you or would you not try to [ __ ]
jennifer once
that's what i'm saying
all i'm saying and this whole everyone's
like he raped them aunt diddy because
not some of them did it very willingly
to get an oscar so let's not maybe some
but um
and others all remember they were all
over 18.
good point allegedly unlike airy spears
that was [ __ ] weird bro i have had a
roller coaster of we have had a roller
coaster of a week with arie spears right
yeah it's been odd it's been super weird
and i don't like it
and
whatever
hill asked a good question who [ __ ]
wrote that sketch it's not even funny
that's the thing